voilà alors avec neuf charlotte
gainsbourg bienvenue sur ce plateau mais
vous allez l'avoir attrapé pouvant pas
ma peau je comprends très bien parce
que c'est sûrement pas facile mais
c'est plus difficile de venir ici
au journal télévisé de tourner un
film avec le dr
deux blessés
vraiment très très très difficile
alors quoi
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une petite fille
tromper charlotte
dans le film
signifie-t-il
citiboutique
c'est une petite fille qui voit une
autre petite fille qui représente pour
elle tout ce qu'elle voudra battre
c'était systématiquement trompée une
petite signe de quelques questions
il tente
pour massimo c'est sur le stade au titre
d'ailleurs
alors moi je vais vous poser une
question charlotte gainsbourg parce que
alors votre mère chan au préfet du
cinéma et fait du théâtre
pauthe avait fait de la musique il
écrit aussi à bordeaux
vous avez envie de diriger vers le
cinéma c'est déjà un choix ou bien
que ce qui nous intéresse le plus
en conseil d'état
lafuma vous êtes vous avez bien fait en
tout cas
cette encore
et quand on chante avec son papa c'est
difficile s'est passé
benoît xvi
je fus cs
il suffit de nous s'il était difficile
précis
petrovic
l'algérie a demandé m il n'avait pas
dit ce moment non
il y tient
et comme johnny r vous a proposé de
tourner
dans les trois cas vous aviez déjà
fait parler de lui alors vous étiez
déjà entraîné
quand on nous propose un film que vous
lisez l'histoire est plutôt de ce fait
il faut demander conseil à
l'ancienne
les clients
c'est une scission
je t'aime plus loin
il souligne combien il convient que
l'été
d'abord comment
avant de demander votre avis
c'est christine
c il faut les prendre
les pannes techniques cette mixité
passion qui le faire
oui on ne ferme plus souvent
inculpé comme l'a fait la fed que
meilleure
on est tout à fait vrai je crois qu'il
fallait que je demande d'abord à
aux parents
néanmoins des choses et puis c'est que
c'est vrai que quand je leur en ai
parlé de de ce projet je remettais pas
sûr si vous voulez de la financière
mangane de réussir à le monter
la charlotte aux poires a préféré la
première à la dernière minute
quand vous allez dans cette histoire
trois petites filles donc charlotte a
une petite copine
avec laquelle la presse les rapports
conjugaux 11 10 pieds tant on se
réconcilie on ne se quitte jamais et
puis tout d'un coup il découvre une
petite fille fabuleuse qui et
concertiste et elle est prête à
quitter son mieux pour suivre la tetris
concertiste cuillère on verra bien
comment ça se passera dans la machine
pour trouver votre petite fille vous
avez dû passer votre temps à la sortie
des écoles au fil des taxis et aux bus
pas du tout pas du tout dans le nord de
bâle charlotte gainsbourg j'ai trouvé
en revanche il échouera qui
en renvoyant le signe paroles et musique
j'avais écrit la moitié de mon
scénario quand j'ai vu ce film et pour
moi cette terre évident que ça n'est
réel il fallait que ce soit elle qui
n'existe pas si vous voulez
demain selon moi c'était que tous les
parents soient pas d'accord
microsoft ce côté-là pour les autres
ça s'est très bien passé alors
l'autre
celles qui étaient là qui concertiste
bon ben il faut bien que quelqu'un est
pas une les notes de musique c'est une
lycéenne comme charlotte
et il se trouve que l approche de
françois et qui est un fou de cinéma
haïti tous les entrants un garçon et
une fille dans sa classe et qui fait un
remake en vidéo de la drôlesse de
jacques doyon
il est entouré à cloner l'erreur pour
hossam amène à la question d
on a l'impression que vous faites petit
à petit une oeuvre vous fait un bon
parcours sans faute dans vos films ça
marche très bien
marche pas ça me fait plaisir ce que
vous me dites mais ç'a vraiment ce
domaine la cei c'est à vous c'est au
public ce critique de bon sens par les
ovationner chacune est une garantie
plaisir de travailler pour moi aller
je ne me rends pas compte du du film
continuité dans tout ça pour l'instant
merci de me permettre c'est charlotte
gainsbourg dont je rappelle le titre de
votre fait une première
l'effrontée à tunis que françois
chabaud coupé mais je crois que c'est
vraiment un très bon film